find either the one point fifth power
using a calculator round your answer to
the nearest hundredth to the nearest
hundred so let's get our trusty ti-85
out and let's evaluate it and different
calculators are different ways but most
graphing captors at least the Texas
Instruments ones it'll work this way
it'll be a little bit different if you
use the HP calculators the old ones that
I had in high school and I think they're
still around are you do it in reverse
polish where you where you you do the
the function and then the arguments
that's a little bit different and if you
use a basic scientific calculator it
also might be a little different so you
might want to make sure that you're
using the functions right but assuming
you're using one of these let me just
show you how to do it so right over here
you see this little e to the X right
over there but it's in orange so the way
to access that orange function is to
press this orange button so this says
let's use the second function of these
buttons right over here if you wanted
this blue function of it you'd press the
blue button so you press this second and
you're pressing the natural log button
but it knows to do e to the X because I
pressed second first so it's e to the
and we just want to take e to the one
point fifth power and we get 4.48 let's
see they said to the nearest hundredth
so 4.48 and there have a one there so we
would round down because it's less than
five so 4.48 so this is approximately
equal to four point four eight and we're
done